[Music]
let me get my tie together
hello
hello everyone out there
welcome everyone
this is
our 100 joke contest finale
i'm joel byers if you didn't know i'm a
comedian host of hot breath podcast
and what we do every single month in our
hopper pro group
is a
joke
writing contest they get a secret theme
and then seven days to write a brand new
90-second set based on that theme
winner gets a hundred dollars and an
interview on hot breath podcast so
there's a lot at stake here today and
you watching live
means you're gonna be a part of that and
you're gonna help watch the three
finalists sets
and then you're gonna vote
for who wins
the
guap and
the pot app i don't know what's more
valuable being on hot breath
or a hundred dollars
but if anybody would like to pay me a
hundred dollars to be on hot breath we
can certainly
see what kind of arrangement we can make
nah i'm totally kidding this can't be
bought shouty you can't be bought too
blessed to stress fam
anyway
so how it's gonna work today my friends
as you're coming in here
is that we are gonna play each of the
finalists
sets
and then you will vote
and then the winner is gonna come on the
show live and get a hundred bucks
so
a lot at stake here today
and if you're watching this like whoa
how do you join oprah's pro well
in the description of this video there
is a link to our online comedy school
and hop breath pro is for graduates of
our master class so when you take the
master class you get access to the hot
breath pro group
to engage with other alumni and also
compete in this and win 100 bucks
so it's a win-win-win for everyone
as we get in here
oh snap
ed ruben already in the building and
bobby
and joan
great to see y'all aaron despiva as well
hey y'all
hey
i was trying i tried to get my hair
gussied up
this morning by putting water on it
that's basically i mean i did shower
this morning i will say i got gussied up
for this
but in the meantime
good morning jack
so it appears
all the finalists are here
and they are ready to rumble
so how it's gonna work my friends
hey hey so how it's gonna work my
friends
hey hey hey so how it's gonna work hey
hey so how it's gonna work hey hey so
how it's gonna work my friends
hey let's go all right
so
as we come in here say hi in the chat
y'all we're about to get started here
we're going to play the top three
finalist sets
and then you
will get to vote on who wins
the historic the legendary
hot breath pro
100 joke contest so
if you don't know the finalists are jack
allen bob kirk and joan fuchsman
all three of them no strangers to the
contest we've been doing this contest
over a year now
and all three of these comics have
submitted to like all of them
um so there's something to be said about
consistency
and that's what this whole contest is
about of just
holding people accountable keeping them
inspired and motivated to write new
material
and that's the whole point of
this 100 joke contest to just give
comics a place to where they can get
paid to write which is pretty cool
so
oh evelyn
evelyn good to see you evelyn thatcher
evelyn just joined hot breath pro
actually
so welcome aboard evelyn great to see
you thanks for joining
this is gonna be a good one here
and bob kirk says morning all he's very
nice
cgm sounds so nice to be seeing this
again oh it's
so nice to be seeing you my friend
and i think
without further ado
are you all ready y'all ready to do this
contest y'all ready to do this contest
oh and bobby said all the finalists
right for the hot breath you in projects
as well you know no big deal
that is a good point bobby
oh karen says kick ass bob ooh
[Music]
fancy pantsy and evelyn said so happy to
be here well we are happy to have you
there evelyn
how exciting
all right so ed rubin said woohoo let's
go
oh it's getting lit shouty we getting
lit shouty we getting lit shall we we're
getting lit charlie we getting lit
i i want the record to show that
i hosted my monthly show last night and
did not dab
once
so i just want the record to show
i did not dab
but i did today bow
all right
so let's get into it here
so first things first my friends
we're going to play each set
and then vote and the voting will be
done on our youtube live stream i'm
going to post a poll on the youtube live
stream for y'all to vote
for your favorite there
so when it comes to voting time
what i can do for those of you watching
on
uh facebook is i can share the youtube
link so you can jump over there and uh
vote on that poll so your voice will be
heard
no voter suppression here despite how i
look i look like i would be out
picketing for voter suppression based on
how i look but
what's happening here
i got a haircut yesterday
and it was kind of
there we go
all right oh hey sandy good morning
sandy
jones said she watched master chef
junior and a kid did the dab
the dab is not going anywhere i just
i think we're onto something there just
a little hit a little ahead of its time
right now but that dad's gonna be back
i'm gonna be in rap videos just dabbing
not even saying or doing anything just
right there
all right
i was saving the dab bobby i was i was i
gave it the night off you know because i
knew i'd be doing it this morning
all right my friends
officially
let's get in to the 100 joke contest so
we're going to be playing
the three sets
you will be voting at the end of
watching these three sets do keep in
mind
my friends that are voting do keep in
the parameters my wife and i like to
watch these submissions together and
shout out to everyone that's submitted
it is not easy
to write
a 90 second set in seven days
the whole process writing it editing it
refining it recording it
like it all requires a lot so shout out
to everyone
who actually
had the idea oh i want to participate
this month and then you
you did it
you made it all the way from idea
to recording it and posting it because i
mean i even
you know i'll do these too and i mean i
did like 10 drafts of the recording you
know so i mean it requires a lot of work
and effort so kudos to everyone
that pushed it through that finish line
even if you're not in the finals just
the exercise and challenge and process
of
creating a 90-second set
in seven days
you just get better you just can't help
but get better at comedy just by doing
that so salute to everyone that did
actually complete it all the way
kudos to you
and now
let's get into the jokes my friends so
we're going to be
reviewing this
on a few levels as you're watching these
keep in mind the theme which this much
theme was spring break
um
and the goal with these contests is for
you to write material that you can
actually use on stage as well so this
theme was spring break
so as you're watching these keep in mind
a few things about
how on theme is it how creative were
they with the theme uh what are the
techniques they're using using different
act outs and callbacks and analogies you
know like the actual joke writing
techniques
and then just
how funny
how rawly purely funny
is it just point blank funny
so
like laughs per minute like do they open
with a quick laugh do they close with a
laugh do they have laps throughout you
know so keep all these things in mind as
you are
watching these under your critical eye
like oh i could do better but then you
didn't even submit or you're not even in
hot breath pro yet and you just think
you can just flex on them from afar
now get in there get in there and see
but we're all about comics helping
comics here so
we are gonna help
a comic today win a hundred bucks so
it's very exciting
all right
good morning chris grulon good morning
all right and we've got aaron despiva
he submitted he submitted
to uh the finals he was close you were
close there are a few debates my wife
and i always have a few debates on who
actually makes it to the finals
but you know who wins
whoever her idea is i'm just kidding
all right
let's get into it my friends thank you
sandy for the heads up on the music
always on top of it
another
finalist um i mean sandy's won a few
times and uh she submitted this time as
well
see it's good to see some familiar faces
and some new faces in here
and it is time all right we've delayed
it long enough
it's time my friends
for the hundred dollar joke contest
finale
so with that being said
um
[Applause]
so
we're gonna do joan
bob and then jack joan bob jack
so first up my friends
it is the one
it is the only
it is joan
dukesman
i'm just kidding i didn't freeze what if
y'all thought i froze how funny ring the
bell
contestant number one joan fuchsman
most of my college days are alcoholic
memories
when i went to ohio university it was a
real party school
we believed our spring break came during
st patrick's day so no one would be on
campus drunkenly emasculating our
beloved bobcat mascot that was the
smartest thing the school ever did
my most memorable spring break doesn't
involve drinking which is why i can
remember it
for this break my mom and i had a new
york city girls break it's unforgettable
because this is when i discovered who my
mom really was
her family lived in new york city she
never told them we were coming because
she didn't want to waste time visiting
them this trip was supposed to be fun
the odds were completely against us
running into her family but we still
went undercover just in case
my brunette mom even more a blonde wig
we studied what new yorkers wore and
dressed accordingly
no funny t-shirts cameras or fanny packs
we looked like we worked on wall street
after a matinee we went to a broadway
cafe
foolishly we took a window seat
suddenly who should appear strolling
down the street my uncle
i've never seen my mom run so fast to
the restroom not even after eating fish
tacos i ducked for cover under the table
crisis averted
that spring break taught me two things
my mom was one sneaky lady and boy did
she give new meaning to runs
to runs give it up for joan fuchsman
everyone show her some love
[Music]
[Applause]
ah all the applause sound effects going
crazy shouty
hold on
there we go
awesome give it up for joan everyone huh
what do you think of joan there to kick
us off
great job there joan
yeah
clapping clapping they say jeff hubbard
said clapping
bobby's getting clapping
yay joan fuchsman
ed said great job and story joan i agree
evelyn liked it evelyn threw a little
slappy emoji on it very nice
bob nice set joan awesome jack allen
great job joan you're always writing
personal material
sandy new meaning to the word runs i
know
how funny joyce liked it oh my gosh look
at the whole the whole hot breath fam is
here look at us
robert baron liked it as well thanks for
sharing the applause there robert
hilarious rory lutz said joan owes me a
hundred dollars she better win
oh that's hilarious
so all right
my friends that is just the first set we
have two more
and then we're gonna be doing our voting
so coming up next
my friends
you all ready y'all ready for this
we got we got we got it we got a hitter
coming up next here
oh dino said funny stuff joan oh
i love that
how nice
i love all the positivity that's what
we're all about here just comics helping
comics so thanks all for
spreading the positivity spreading the
love in here that's what it's all about
my friends
and joseph lawson asked how do i get in
this contest this contest is for
graduates of our
writing master class so
in the description of this
youtube you'll see a link to our hot
breath pro comedy school and there
you'll see links to our master classes
and all graduates
are in their own private facebook group
where they do writing rooms together we
do this monthly contest and much more so
it's linked in the description
and now oh karen said funny stuff very
nice
well i love all the positivity and love
but we have two more in this contest so
we mustn't waste any more time my friend
and the next
comedian of the march
finals
it's mr bob kirk ring the bell
here we go
bumpkirk spring break
florida sun sea and sand in my shorts oh
alligators fire ants and flying
cockroaches yeah it's my idea of a great
vacation oh a senior sunbather had that
sun-soaked leathery skin she looked like
a couch with sunspots and skin tags and
a smile that could kill she was an
alligator in a thong
and was happy to see me
i had seven young women encircle me on
the beach i think it was because of the
whales
i thought i was getting mugged and they
asked me to be their sugar daddy i said
i'm diabetic but i'd be happy to go into
sugar shock and debt for you
so as it turned out i was getting mugged
some people refer to me as an old geezer
i prefer pleaser if i could be
reincarnated i come back as a thong yeah
you know like cisco says the thong song
let me see
that thong oh scandalous it's a speedo
day at the beach but we were on the
senior beach so it was anything but
speed
workers were getting stuck in the sand
and scooters were getting towed out oh
seniors had fallen down and couldn't get
up they were like turtles on their back
let me see that though oh scandalous
oh my gosh
can we go for bob kirk everyone
[Music]
nicely done there bob oh
see wasn't that worth just seeing bob
sing the thong song
and he probably thinks it's in
it's in
in vogue right now he's like yo i just
heard this new thong song
i think it's got potential to be a hit
oh jack island like the alligator in a
thong
ah that's great he said fantastic bob
joan liked it too she said so much
so funny bob and so much energy oh
evelyn liked it as well evelyn said so
funny
bobby said great job bob
sandy likes the
the couch joke and the whole senior
beach yeah
lynne says lol bob
[Music]
a lot of good ones coming in here
evelyn likes the thong song
dino said cisco's eating his heart out
yeah right cisco watch out we've got bob
kirk coming at you
hmm
and
ed rubin said so full of energy love the
thong and sugar stuff yeah
karen likes it walker's getting stuck in
the sand yeah it's very visual that's
the best part about seeing
these contests every month and seeing
people's writing is just what people
will do with a theme with the same theme
but take it in completely different ways
like my theme is getting a haircut and
then it's going in all sorts of
different ways look at that
oh
[Music]
my friends
it's been good it's been real
but we still have one more my friends we
have just one more and then we are doing
the live voting and then
you will determine
who wins
the march 2022
100 joke contest
this is a big deal now this is a big
deal
okay the big deal a lot of steak here so
we appreciate all y'all for hanging out
we appreciate y'all for
who those of you who submitted those of
you participating in this live stream
we love you all so much we appreciate
you
being part of our mission here at hop
breath of cultivating the next
generation of great comics so
jeff hubbard said hilarious stuff bob
very nice it was hilarious stuff
and now
it is time
for the final contestant
of the hundred dollar joke contest
and that is
mr
jack
allen
my friends jack allen
coming to the stage
a family tampervan spring break in the
british countryside
staring across those grassy plains
through the window because it's bloody
raining
yeah my dad insisted we only went on
this holiday because i needed to be
more in touch with nature
definitely not because he's had his
hours cut work yes
i had to speak to the animals for
entertainment
oh what's that cow
oh yes i agree
this holiday is child abuse yeah
okay cow um
i'm out of milk for my cereal so
i'm gonna need to go on those others
oh
daisy
it's flowing out of you this morning
you know i did address my boredom
concerns to my dad
dad it's spring break
where's the bikinis and the beer
look
i'll drink the beer
and your mother's got a bikini
oh christ
to be fair
all her pilates classes were paying off
you know
don't worry
my mum said
jack
if the campervan breaks out on the way
back
that just means
more time together as a family
yeah
good for jack one time everyone make
some noise for
jack allen
[Music]
a little applause sound a break for you
there
very nice oh my gosh
well it is time my friends
holy comedy
it is now time
to see who wins
the match hot breath pro 100 joke
contest so thank you all for tuning in
you have seen
the submissions
now it's time to vote for only one my
friends only vote for one
oh sandy liked the um
the thing with daisy
oh bob said
great job jack moo bobby light because
it's always raining
it's always bloody raining lynn said
great job jack
dino liked it ed loves it the cow
milking
karen loved it oh my gosh a lot of love
coming in here more time together as a
family
evelyn says sandra said everyone was so
funny i know but there can only be one
winner
and it is up to you hot breath verse
right now
to vote for who the winner is
so in the uh the facebook live streams i
have posted a link to the youtube live
stream where in
the live chat
you will see an opportunity to cast your
votes
live
oh what's up fresh out of bed good to
see you fam
watching over on youtube joe
joe weagle
wiggle
i have my first stand-up show on
wednesday congratulations joe that's
great buddy
big step there big step
so what we're gonna do here my friends
we're gonna take a moment
to do a little voting
take a moment to
do a little voting
to take a moment to
to do a little voting hey we're taking a
moment to vote hey we taking a moment to
vote hey we're taking a moment to vote
everybody go and
vote no it ain't wrote it's a a vote for
the hundred dollar joke contest bro
to the 100
i'm a rapper did you know we out here
trapping
as we go and it flows
from my nose
to my toes what's up bros
and
women we're all inclusive here because
we ought beat a winning
it's spinning
it's standing ooh this song kind of got
me grinning
all right
oh miss the truth says seriously such a
hard vote
there can only be one my friends there
can only be one
but i'm excited to see who it is i
appreciate all the offer
hanging out
showing love on this sunday morning i
know y'all could be doing anything right
now but i do appreciate y'all hanging
out with us and supporting this mission
here at hot breath
so as you're over on youtube if you
haven't subscribed yet go ahead and
subscribe to our youtube channel we're
trying to hit 50 000 subscribers this
year
so do hit that subscribe button if
you're not subscribed yet and that's
gonna help us
[Music]
you don't see the voting link
well it's in the youtube live chat it's
in this live chat
i mean it yeah in the youtube live chat
i don't know what else
maybe you need to be logged in
maybe you need to be logged in on like
your google youtube
[Music]
because people are voting so people are
finding it
concrete nurtured rose
good to see you my friend said i need to
start writing again yeah it's all a
process
this contest is a great way to hold you
accountable to write
we do a daily writing club in our
facebook group i do a weekly live stream
about writing on wednesday mornings i
mean there's a lot of
fun opportunities for you to
get in and get accountable you know
sandra voted very nice this is so
exciting so
yes mike that is where the voting is the
voting is in our youtube
which
those of you if you look right here
you can see
the live chat
and then to the right of it here
is where the voting is
where the poll is you see so right now
bob kirk
coming in hot
coming in hot so bob is in the lead
right now
we'll give it another minute
but it's looking like bob kirk is having
his way with it at the moment so we
shall see
starts at 10 yes yep well every day in
our facebook group
uh bobby posts a word of the day where
you write a joke
using that word and then on wednesdays
at 10
i go live and we do the exercise live
hey
hey hey hey hey hey
so evelyn to vote i see you over here on
youtube thanks for making the jump
you should see a poll in the live chat
there should be a poll to where you can
vote for who wins oh man jones making a
little bit of a comeback here oh no
oh no
how exciting
so get your votes in because we are
about to end our
round of voting so if you're just tuning
in here this is our monthly
joke writing contest where the winner
gets a hundred bucks and an interview on
hop breath podcast so this is for
members of our hot breath pro community
and we are doing voting right now
and we're about to announce this month's
winner and if you want to participate in
future contests we do
just go into the description of this
video join one of our master classes and
all graduates
entry into this hundred dollar joke
contest every single month
the contests are 90 second sets
fresh out of bed
90 second sets
seven days that is no easy feat
alright
well here we go my friends
it appears
we have a clear
winner for this one it was tight it was
tight
it was a bit tight here
you know you could see though
just
see you see the proof right here no fake
news here
the voting has been decided and it looks
like
today's
winner
of the
march
100 joke contest
it goes to the man
the legend
bob kirk everyone make some noise for
bob kirk so well deserved
yeah
congratulations bob
bravo my friend so we're gonna bring bro
brob
we're gonna bring bob on live
hopefully he can figure out technology
and get on live
but we shall see
evelyn your vote went through
yeah your vote went through i saw
bob went up he actually won
now
oh look karen said yahoo
concrete nurtured rose
way to go bob
joan says congrats bob's so funny oh
how lovely
baboo
so bob i have sent you a link
um to join the live stream i sent you a
link on facebook and just give me a
moment and then we will uh bring you on
to the show once you get into the green
room
um bob said he has to change computers
hilarious
karen with the applause
how lovely
joyce said congratulations bob
jack likes it bob fantastic imagery in
your set well deserved chris grulon said
congrats bob
bobby congratulations great sets
everyone says bob yeah i agree
oh
evelyn said congratulations bob
yay
lynn
congrats bob dino congrats to bob funny
sets from all the comedians
oh
jeff hubbard said nice job everyone
first time to participate in this format
in voting congrats bob
oh well thanks jeff
thanks for hanging out buddy
all right everyone
okay so we're about to bring bob on
my friends
this is very exciting
so prepare yourselves my friends
because this is going to be uh
tomorrow's podcast as well
so what we're gonna do here
we're gonna play his set again
and then we're gonna bring him on live
so thank you to everyone that voted
thank you everyone that participated in
has been hanging out with this
and now let's get into it here so we're
gonna pl i'm gonna do the intro we're
gonna play his set
and
then um we're gonna bring bob on live
for an interview and you can feel free
to ask him questions as well about his
set and his writing process and such
but here we go
all right
oh and i love seeing that
evelyn said this was super fun great
sets everyone yeah evelyn you're gonna
have to compete in next month
that's the whole goal of this set is
just to inspire comics to write new
material
and pay them
so here we go
my friends
all right
what is goodie hot breath the verse
welcome back to hot breath the show
where you learn comedy from the pros i'm
your host comedian joel byers and we are
taking
a brief departure from our comedy author
series if you've been listening to the
podcast you've heard us
posting interviews with comedy authors
like greg dean and judy carter and john
vorhaus
but we're taking a week off from that to
share the winner of our monthly hundred
joke contest in our hot breath pro
community we do a contest every month
where the winner gets a hundred bucks
and an interview
on hot breath and this is this month's
interview
so buckle up
and meet
the very funny winner of our march
contest
mr bob kirk
and then i'll play his set which
will take me a moment
oh here it is
all right
bumpkirk spring break oh florida sun sea
and sand in my shorts oh alligators fire
ants and flying cockroaches yeah it's my
idea of a great vacation oh a senior
sunbather had that sun-soaked leathery
skin she looked like a couch with
sunspots and skin tags and a smile that
could kill she was an alligator in a fog
and was happy to see me
i had seven young women encircle me on
the beach i think it was because of the
whales
i thought i was getting mugged and they
asked me to be their sugar daddy i said
i'm diabetic but i'd be happy to go into
sugar shock and debt for you so as it
turned out i was getting mugged
some people refer to me as an old geezer
i prefer pleaser
if i could be reincarnated i come back
as a thong yeah you know like cisco says
the thong song
let me see that thong oh scandalous it
was speedo day at the beach but we were
on the senior beach so it was anything
but speed
walkers were getting stuck in the sand
and scooters were getting towed out oh
seniors had fallen down and couldn't get
up they were like turtles on their back
let me see that dog oh scandalous
[Music]
all right bob kirk everyone bobby
how are you
what's happening
i haven't taken this off in a week
[Laughter]
it looks good on you it really brings
out the gray in your hair
yeah great great
it's like the you know the sports teams
the the players the professional players
that you know keep the same socks
you know they don't change well i'm
trying to start a comedy tradition here
i like it yes so many broke comics
appreciate your new tradition but
they're like i only have one pair of
clothes anyway so this is perfect
it's like superstition right yeah
exactly well hey whatever you did it
worked so congrats on winning bob is so
cool
thanks thanks it was it was you know i
have to say this this spring break theme
it was i think it was one of the tougher
ones to write
yeah
i think a lot of people maybe had
trouble with it you know just
talking to different people and and all
that you know i'm thinking
well i went oh and um concrete nurtured
rose says sugar daddy of the year
is what people love that scandalous line
which is hilarious
but i guess i was thinking
yeah i made the theme spring break
i was just thinking it was topical and i
thought it would inspire like joan
joan got like a super personal story out
about like her growing up you know so i
was hoping that the theme of spring
break would kind of inspire
nostalgia or
like i don't know it did seem like
people people commented that this was
like the a tougher one but yeah yeah
and i gotta say it's hard y'all comedy
is hard what do you mean comedy's hard
no
i couldn't be in better company than
with joan and jack
yeah they work hard they're they're
super nice and
i mean joan runs her her uh her monday
night room and jack is usually in the
three of us are usually in there so i
think
our dna is their dna is on my set
somewhere
oh yeah
yeah well yeah because they're given you
know everybody throws tags out or or
suggestions so it's nice to have
people to to bounce that stuff off right
for sure it's so important yeah yeah
and a shout out to chris mulan for the
ref room i mean it's amazing there's a
lot of people in there can i give them a
shout out shout them out from the
hilltops
big big uh shout out to chris i think
chris was the one that suggested that i
should do the thong song
oh my gosh
how funny yeah yeah and and and to dino
and jones in there sarah quinton
uh juan carlos bernice axe axel slash
rory
andy and timothy and
ben just joined uh ben webb and uh
lorna and ray i say
oh so
i think there's at least five people in
there every day monday to
friday
three three p.m eastern that's awesome
three three to the last one shuts the
lights off
jack allen says legend
and um
jones said thanks bob it's always fun to
work with you and osmora said congrats
bob as well so
yeah a lot of love coming in for bob
wow it's a lot of fun
that's like nine
nine drops later
nine drafts yeah yeah yeah oh my gosh
[Music]
oh my gosh
nice
wow so where did you
what what's your favorite joke from this
set
i don't know you know
i like the uh the seniors the speed of
you know
seniors on the beach anything but speed
right
speed
although the thought the
the thong song is is fun too it took me
a while to get that i had to listen to
that a lot
[Laughter]
to get the beat down to get the rhythm
down yeah yeah
it was either that or dmx i was
the thong song is perfect i loved it
yeah
go ahead and i was gonna say evelyn said
all that hard work paid off yeah
yeah yeah and the uh
i never really went to florida that much
in uh you know for spring break as a kid
you know where as a
young adult but i had to do research so
i went on youtube and punched in spring
break
and
i think myrtle was getting upset because
i was spending hours on the computer
bob was pulling up girls gone wild
footage that's what he was doing that
was my research
i can see why because there's a lot of
moving violations oh
bob he's he's still on a roll here
arrest this man for being illegally
funny
somebody said what are the whales on
your shirt
i don't i was hoping they were sperm
whales
oh
bob
i know i canceled that hundred dollars
is going to your legal fees for us
scrubbing this interview from the
internet that's
oh and martha said bob is the man very
nice
thanks so much
ed liked the turtles on their back joke
too
yeah yeah i just i just try to be i
really thought uh visually you know uh
with this one you know what can you do
on a beach and what you know
um
so i thought
you know i was thinking turtles because
turtles actually it wasn't florida tampa
and we walked up the beach and there are
areas that are for
turtles in the sand in that right and uh
i guess you know conserving them or
whatever so
i think i got that idea from there you
know yeah and you said the theme was
difficult but then you won so like what
did you do or like you know it was hard
but you still did it like what was kind
of the process for this set
well i actually i did i did watch some
videos on on youtube right i punched in
like
somehow i got seniors play 10 10 top
places of florida where not to live
hilarious here's another talking about
crime they're talking about this
everybody thinks you know and then
reading about the the the fire ants and
flying cockroaches i got oh my god
really
this sounds like my kind of vacation
bugs
i'm like i'm like a magnet towards bugs
at least up north mosquitoes love me i
think because of the sugar in my blood
right it's like so sweet
delicious
yeah yeah
so
yeah that that uh
i don't know and then the image i've
seen you know
women you know i guess like sun
worshipers uh maybe not so much now
because they had sunscreen but i
remember
years ago like people do get that
leathery skin you know if they're out in
the sun a lot and i just had this image
of this
this older woman
you know just like
you know
this
leather and then the couch line and all
that so i don't know i try to be pretty
visual in in uh
you know with that you know but yeah and
then like the leathery skin the
alligator like how did the alligator
misdirect come in because it started out
you researching and then sun and
leathery skin and then you found the
punchline with the alligator
yeah yeah and
you know this sunspots you think people
you know get those brown spots and
skin tags i just sort of mushed it all
together
i don't know
oh and how did you come up with like
alligator did you just think of what
else is leathery skin
well because they did talk in this video
that i watched it talked about the
flying ass cockroaches and and
alligators they're a big problem like on
golf courses and all that like don't go
swimming in any
body of water necessarily there you're
going to get munched you see you know
there's alligators all over the place so
i thought i thought
what if i put the alligator
you know as a sunbather you know the
skin the skin
i don't know
my mind's crazy
no i love it all started with research
though that's very interesting of
researching the topic before writing
about it that's really interesting
yeah because i didn't want to go typical
like just drinking you know i know i
know a lot of kids you know they're 20
something of course they're gonna be
drinking and partying and all that and
that's what they look like on that beach
anyway yeah yeah i was having a lot of
nostalgia doing this one he's like back
in my day we drank a
mad dog 20 20.
i like okay
like jones slide you know it's because i
didn't drink i remember just yeah
exactly exactly that was great
yeah
trying to stay a little bit away from
that you know because that's i guess
more typical right just
getting
blotted drunk i know
yeah yeah that was it all three
finalists had like their own unique
point of view on spring break and no one
took it to that
like everyone's set was personal which
always which always shines through you
know
yeah
yeah i know i was thinking okay what
would happen if i go you know thinking
about going
down to the
beach like that now you know yeah
other than just walking a nice stroll
along the beach you know
and i i just yeah
it's funny i start with a lot
of words i think i think some of them
some of the drafts were like seven 800
words and then just trying to hone them
hone them down as i as i i get and i
find that anywhere from like 175 to
about 220 words
can make up the the 90 seconds right
usually that's what i found from doing
all the uh
you know all the different drafts
yeah because you um
you've done like every contest
like you've submitted to basically every
single one yeah
so yeah you're getting your system down
that's cool
but i think too it's a it's a good
challenge like you said it and i al with
all with all the different contests i
usually end up with a good five minutes
you know that i can use on stage and
here's another reason just to do the
contest even
not necessarily that you get in the
finals
but
the fact that i uh tape it and i put it
on facebook
i've got the last uh three contests i've
got bookings from it
so
yeah yeah people get a hold of me to to
get bookings so um
with with this last one
i had a a booking to do a you know
online show
so i i got i got a chance to run
the uh the spring break yeah stuff
within my
seven minute set right so
um
so it it like i i went to nine drafts i
was ready with eight and i took a chunk
out and said no
you know
oh that's so cool
they're not laughing they're staring
right what's going on is he having a
stroke
at any moment there's like is bob okay
we always have to make sure
so i got a chance to run it which which
is good i know other people do too but
uh
it's kind of a nice uh
you know offshoot of that to be able to
get booked
yeah that's really cool i love hearing
that
yeah that's yeah uh nurtured rose said
so inspiring he wrote nine drafts i'm
usually pinning my set right before i
get on stage
yeah
yeah well i mean
i always try to leave room for uh you
know change or improv there's been a
number of times
when i've uh taped it because you got to
do it right through right i think i did
like 10 ten
ten runs of this one or ten rehearsals
oh i literally like mine too was like i
did like ten rehearsals yeah
hey i noticed two you used like three
different songs in yours
i'm taking a piece out of your book
there
yeah that's like three three songs in 90
seconds
i'll have to pump it up to four now
pretty soon
[Laughter]
whatever fills the time would it stretch
it out
for sure
so
anyway that that's uh
yeah that was a nice sort of offshoot of
that to get to get uh bookings from it
for sure yeah i love hearing that
yeah um
jack allen
asked how did you how do you decide on
your comedy style slash persona the
fast-paced punches and energetic style
act outs
i know i just well like i said with the
visual with the i i thought you know
think of the beach and those you know
the scooters and the walkers like you're
not gonna get very far with a walker on
sand you know
that's great
i i
i i did get a i'll have to tell you a
story that i was a member of uh this pwp
group and they had a big thing down uh
in uh virginia right virginia beach
and older people like people that have
pwp parents without partners you know so
they're separated or divorced and they
have kids right so it's a good group
there's a chapters all over the states
there was chapters in canada too but um
so they did
you know events for kids and events for
you know the adults and they had a thing
down there in virginia beach like a
dance get together
whatever and they're they're older women
so we're at one this is years ago this
is before myrtle so
okay
get mad
bob has a past everyone yeah
anyway anyway what happened was we're on
the beach playing frisbee
and uh
these women from that i had met the
night before at this function right
they were on the beach there's like five
of them and they did come around and
like circle circle us right it's like
well they're a little bit older right
and the one woman said to me this didn't
make it in the set but i was
almost
she said to me would you would you like
to come up to my room and see my crabs
and i'd go
i go what
what
wow that's quite an opening line you
know to meet somebody
[Laughter]
i mean would you like to
i go i don't think so she goes no you
got the wrong idea in the store over
there like a souvenir shop they actually
sold blue crabs
and she
cut them up in her room right and that
was her icebreaker yeah yeah i guess so
wow
the gift that keeps on giving there
yeah
i gotta go get the frisbee okay
[Laughter]
you know they were like cougars but a
little older with you know the dentures
come out so you're only going to get gum
to death oh heavens we're getting
canceled today bob's on a roll
that's why that didn't make it in
[Laughter]
i'm so grateful you did the rift room
and were able to
edit things down and out yeah
yeah
i'm trying to be too i am trying to be
clean
yeah or corporate yeah i think so you
can do that you're very you all your
humor is very silly and goofy you know
it doesn't need to be dirty
yeah
yeah unless you want it to be you know i
don't tell people what they should or
shouldn't do so my set could be naughty
or nice yeah
in that hat
you know maybe neither we're just like
let's get him a stylist but
yeah yeah
no it looks good
half this interview is just how you look
and people are listening on the podcast
like what
what do you mean how does he look
they're listening to the audio
all right yeah it's a podcast have the
great visual pictures
[Music]
that's incredible you did nine drafts
that's wow
but you know it's funny though um
joel like usually i do seven or eight
nine like i'm up there
because every day i'm you know because
you only have the the week so
every time i'm writing every day right
right right
and i i have to do a shout out too to
jerry corley a lot of his classes help
in a lot of his structures and
and all that you know mm-hmm
yeah yeah
that signed up or were in the room today
were from you know classes and all that
you know evelyn and uh oh yeah evelyn
just joined hot breath pro there
yeah yeah that's so cool
i love hearing that i just love hearing
comics helping comics that's so fun yeah
and i have to hand it to you for setting
this whole thing up you know having a
place where you know
the comics can meet and uh
exchange ideas and and all of that it's
it's great it's it's
keeping us going you know
hey it keeps me going just as much my
friend that's for sure
yeah and it's positive you know so
it's terrific so
it's a the benefit to it you know
yeah well thanks for taking it so
seriously you compete in like every
contest you're always so active and
supportive i mean i really
i really appreciate it you know
it makes my heart smile
yeah
and part of the thing with the drafts is
i just you know whatever comes into my
head
i write it down you know and that's why
so many drafts too because i know all
the ideas aren't going to make it to the
to the final page just get them all out
first and then
yeah yeah whatever's in my head i guess
that too is sort of from my improv
background background you know just
spit it out get it out there right it's
almost like the way i think of it it's
like a
funnel right finger so all the ideas and
then and then yeah you know you hone it
down
right and that that is also i think what
holds people back from writing a lot of
the time is like having the
needing the first draft to be perfect or
even funny like a lot of times instead
of just starting we'll like talk
ourselves out well this isn't even funny
this is dumb why even start but starting
is really the hardest part and it's just
like you said getting it out there
and then refining it and rewriting it
and editing it you got to start
somewhere
yeah so get get your general ideas just
like get it out on the page and
worry about yeah i think
what you're talking about is a lot of
people want to edit right off the top
out of their head they want to they're
editing already before they put it on
the page right
i think what i do is just get it on the
page and worry about editing after you
know
yeah where you can
take things and say okay what structure
can i work with or what can i use here
you know all of that right
exactly oh karen said uh congrats bob
good morning eyeopener
from kaz
yeah kaz is in uh
with jerry yeah nice yeah oh and evelyn
says jerry's awesome said what a fun
supportive community thanks for creating
this group joel
oh
yeah oh have fun thanks evelyn i i
brought a busload with me i see that
thanks bob
the og coming through we appreciate you
buddy
i love it oh yeah and aaron says i
always write more jokes than i used to
brainstorm
yeah yeah
and what i find is after the contest now
i'll go back through some of my drafts
and say okay what can i what can i use
to make it you know five minutes seven
minutes on on on this theme you know uh
actually i did that when when what was
the one romance you had a while a while
back was it romance i think that was
yeah we had one for valentine's day that
was like romance i think
yeah i've got a whack of stuff
on that i mean
a lot i mean i'm making a whole
probably 45 minutes out of it
so
i got all kinds of
all kinds of
you had i'm sure you did some googling
there too
you're reading these books and i go well
yeah am i getting romantic
she goes no
kama sutra for dummies
well so i haven't hit that one yet
this is more like you know buy gifts rap
gifts you know don't give us checks
as a gift or especially hopefully they
don't bounce but you know yeah yeah
do a lot of things for each other so you
know when i found out that whether
you're married or in a relationship
it can
it takes work
it's going to be a little bit of work
you know
amen to that
yeah so i'm learning
what was it the book i'm reading is a
thousand and one ways uh
to be romantic
oh wow it's it's you've gotta you've
gotta uh
uh and that says
on the book title it says worth
memorizing
i have trouble with 90 seconds never
mind a thousand or one a thousand and
one one ways
romantic sounds like a joke book
dude i mean this is so cool
congratulations um
is uh is there anything else you want to
say about the set or anything you would
like to
say here bob
um not really
no you you won
if you're in toronto and up north come
and see me at deb's comedy then i got
booked for seven months there
deb's comedy den
yeah it's engravenhurst
it's a way it's a long drive
for anyone up in the toronto area
they're like what
yeah deb boschman she's a producer and
performer so
hey don't downplay it that's a big deal
bob
yeah yeah and linda camacho for having
me on her shows so
that that's uh that's fun
nice and good and shout out to them too
so anybody that ever booked me you know
i'll get the list
i look forward to doing a show together
someday
yeah
i know i know all this the last two
years have been
oh yeah now the masking gloves are
coming off joel up here anyway
yeah they're pretty much here as well i
think it's
yeah yeah which is great
yeah to get a goat and and do some
traveling do some joking but it's nice
to be online too
you don't have to spend the money on gas
exactly or pants you know it's um yeah
no i'm just kidding
i can i can pay i can pay this off now
he bought it on layaway from uh
marshalls so now he can go finish buying
his whale shirt with his
contest winnings
i know myrtle say well you got the
hundred bucks now why don't you be
romantic let's go out for dinner
[Laughter]
you're reinvesting into the comedy
business
you're gonna take her out so you can get
more material that's all
yeah
she was happy about this one because i
didn't mention her once so she was happy
my wife does the same when i don't
mention her yeah
well
congratulations bob uh people sent jack
said congratulations
bob bobby's saying congratulations bob
great interview and
great sets to joan and jack as well so
yeah
they were i couldn't think of two nicer
people to be in the finals with that's
for sure i'm not just saying that i like
them i genuinely like them and they're
funny i agree i totally agree yeah
so where where can uh people
connect with you bob and
shout out you know what i've been on
tick tock a little well on facebook um
bob kirk and then i've got what bob kirk
comedy on tick tock
and if i can figure out instagram i'll
get on there someday
how's the tick tock going you're on the
i want to talk
the geriatric tick tock is that right
yeah
it's a little slower yeah
yeah i get up well i need help with
editing and all that hey if there's
anybody that's a social media guru then
uh
let's
get a hold of me oh get a hold of bobby
he's got a hundred dollars burning a
hole in his pocket
it sounds like his his lady is about to
change that for you though yeah i'm
wrestling or a fight for that hundred
dollars yeah
gonna help you divest some of your
abundance is what they say it's not what
they say all right
oh that's good that's good yeah social
media i know what tick tock you can edit
it right in the thing but that's what i
i'm a little slow on the uptake of that
so it's all right you're learning i'm
yeah i'm i'm actually going to take a a
little course next week on some
wednesdays and fridays so on tick tock
no just on social media in general
really
yeah remember
when i did this before joe we were you
know you send out a vhs state but they
don't take them anymore nope they
definitely don't nope
even a dvd no not likely
no not anymore nope it's all online now
yeah
well awesome yeah and it's bob kirk
comedy on tick tock you said yeah so go
follow bob bob's got to go viral man
look at you in this hat
like you're on there but you've got to
like i think you got to post every day
on these things on on tick tock anyway
oh yeah usually like at least once a day
yeah i've heard like four times a day or
six times a day i mean it's whatever you
can do i'm
i'm working on it you know i'm i'm most
consistent on instagram right now
it's kind of just wherever you can
naturally
put in the most consistent work and then
kind of expand from there so i'm just
trying to
one bite at a time you know like i guess
when you think about it it's like
marketing yourself right so you have to
spend some time doing that
but it takes away from my writing
oh yeah every single yeah it's all a
balance and what what's what's it worth
you know because
you know producing your own show
is something i like tell comics they
should they should do if they want to
you know
right make money but also
develop faster because you're hosting
your own show
but the caveat to hosting your own show
is
okay you're booking your own show you're
you're having to like find a venue
you're having to work with the venue and
discuss the show
you're having to market the show and
like there's so many things
take away yeah so anything you decide to
do starting a podcast okay so now that's
gonna be taking away a lot of time from
things you could be doing with writing
or performing you know every
everything's a balance and it's just
what's it worth to you you know what's
what's the exchange worth so it's
everything yeah everything is going to
require some sort of time and effort so
you just want to make sure it's worth it
so i know and then there's you know the
the work uh
life bounce with your
significant other oh of course and then
family yes that matters
that's that's that's a big thing
out of everything i said
i just went straight from comedian not a
person at all just you know you produce
your own show your own podcast you're
like yeah we have a family as well
they would probably appreciate
i say you want to see me tune into hot
breath there you go
that's where we all are now no families
anymore we're just glued to the computer
yeah and family it's all it's all a
balancing act dude it's all a balance
but
you know
if you if you're just kind of doing what
you love and we love comedy
yeah this is true and our families
yeah
our families and comedy maybe the
reversal
yes yes yes yes
yeah good point yeah family first
oh my gosh
well i think people uh people listening
to this definitely go connect with bob
go follow him on tick tock
and um connect with him on facebook also
bob's a hot breath og
you've showed so much love and it's been
so much fun to see your
comedy just develop
since since we met you know at the
beginning of the pandemic i mean it
really yeah it's come to life it's
really cool to see
that's good
it's it's good to
you know the biggest thing i think is
being consistent in writing every day
like doing like the uh you know bobby
poach the post the joke every day and
then
and then you know emory with the the
night time i mean you know the random
words of the day at 10 and 10 you know
or or 10 or 9 50 in the morning and 10
at night you know eastern that you know
to do that it just gets the the brain
going you know if you can uh post a joke
you know for sure for sure and generally
what i'll do is is do it but i'll
probably write 10 others you know but i
won't put submit i just write them so
i find that for me is a good warm-up in
the morning that's sort of like my
warm-up and get going and then go into
uh other other stuff other material
like this romantic thing yeah
well yeah speaking of family you can go
spend time
go you go spend time with your family go
uh go spend your winnings
yeah on a romantic getaway a hundred
dollars you won't get too far i guess
you'll get to
guess my tank the guy oh yeah
that's gonna be a gift
honey i got a full tank
joke money look out
depending on your car it may be a full
tank or not yeah
yeah
hilarious
but yeah the writing every day is good i
think that's the biggest thing is being
consistent and doing it you know and
the joke contest every month is is a
great uh
you know forces you like you said the
weak it's like constriction develops
creativity you know so i think you
try to
you know it's like a ringing out a towel
for all you can all that it's worth
for the 90 seconds you know what can you
come as very wise mr cook very wise
well let's land this plane i'm almost
lunch isn't it y'all i'm i'm about to go
do yard work dude i'm about to be
planting
we've got we can cook for another three
hours man hydrangeas some tea olives
we got a little bit of we got some
shrubs we're getting we're getting a
perimeter privacy going we're getting
our perimeter privacy going you know
and it's first day of spring y'all first
day of spring
yeah it's great the birds are singing
it's raining
yeah so yeah i'm about to be going to do
hard work but
i appreciate you so much there bob
congratulations my friend
okay it was a lot of fun to thank
everybody for all your kind words and
support and appreciate it yeah yeah of
course
keep on writing exactly and performing
well congratulations bob kirk show bob
some love here everyone let's give him
some love
thanks a lot joel absolutely have a good
day bob
all right you guys take care congrats
buddy
bye
[Music]
all right
oh really fun interview cool
thank you
are we done
we're still on
people are saying
evelyn said a really fun interview
cool
um
dino said thanks for the talk bob great
advice and inspiration
bobby said angel's on y'all jack allen
great stuff guys
so yes we are done we are landing the
plane
all right that's great
have a good day bob okay thanks joel
appreciate it man bye
as always bye-bye
all right all right everyone there it is
my friends
there it is bob kirk
the winner
isn't that a great isn't that great
lynn said funny interview i love it
awesome
oh let me record the outro
there it is hot breath the verse
wait let's take two on that
there you have it hot breath the verse
reach out to bob let him know how much
you enjoyed this interview and found his
interview so inspiring and helpful all
right we're gonna do take through take
three
there it is hot breath verse if you
found this interview helpful reach out
to bob let him know
that his interview was super helpful and
inspirational and if you want to
participate in next month's contest and
compete with people like me and bob and
jack and joan
all you gotta do is go into the
description of this episode join one of
our master classes and you get
automatically entered into this contest
every single month but that is it my
friends next week we are back with our
comedy author series
interviewing the top comedy authors in
the world
so until next monday
right here
on hot
breath
[Music]
oh wasn't that fun
y'all got all the inside sauce there the
intro the outro the interview
but alas my friends
it is time
we have arrived to that time
in the live stream
where we go forth with our days
it's sunday it's the first day of spring
so that's very exciting so
go on now gonna get
gone get now you here
all right
let's get out of here thank y'all so
much for spending your time with us on
this sunday oh my gosh i appreciate it
so much
and now
it is time my friends
we'll be back
with another contest next month
but in the meantime every
week on youtube we do a live
joke feedback live stream on youtube on
tuesdays at five
wednesdays at 10 a.m i do a live joke
writing contest and then wednesdays at 5
p.m i do a live q a as well so a lot
here to help you level up your comedy
game
all you got to do is subscribe to this
youtube channel
and you'll get and stay in on the no if
you want to take part in that daily
writing contest like bob was talking
about we do that in our facebook group
just search hop breath
on facebook and you'll find it
but now
let's get out of here thank you chewie
bless you as well my friend and bless
all of y'all for hanging out i love you
so much
you all have a good day out there y'all
happy tree planting will do
evelyn thank y'all so much
and y'all have a good day out there all
right
bye y'all
angel's on y'all